Uh, pregnant women smell soul. Wonderful.
Okay.
I'm actually doing a piece on motherhood.
Really?
Did you know embryonic fluid is
actually urine? Let's open that wine.
We're having a baby too. Yeah. How far
along are you? I'm not actually pregnant.
We have a surrogate.
I'm Kiki and Wayne and Tina's
baby surrogate mom. Did
you screwed? Sorry again.
Whoa.
I think Donna's boning someone else.
Okay. Suppose he is. They care.
Of course I care.
There are five phases of a woman's life.
I am in phase four.
You have to be a mother.
If government and businesses are
going to devalue women's work and make
motherhood economically unfeasible,
why not outsource it?
See, this is why people
hate liberals. Huh?
I made fresh orange juice for Karen.
Folic acid.
Tina is like a sperm donor.
I'm so not like a sperm donor.
God, I feel so bad. Wow.
Let's welcome to the
stage at least Reiner,
David Allen face and Madeline didn't
know. No, just to get things started.
We celebrated International
Women's Day on Friday.
Did anyone do anything
exciting and celebration? Yeah.
I wish shooting actually. But,
um, at the end of the day live in,
I made a video. We, I work
a lot with equality now,
which is another amazing organization.
And they asked a lot of different women
to make a video about what freedom means
to them. And I wanted to
wait and do it with live. So,
so if you check my Instagram,
yeah.
Freedom means to me.
Yeah. That's excellent.
And we just did so many
corporate presentations.
We did a really large global
presentation for Sony,
for all the divisions of Sony.
Okay.
And then the day before I did
a big presentation for a Carew,
which is the children's advertising
and online, um, organization.
So it was a busy presentation week.
Yeah.
Yeah, I would imagine it's kind of peak
season for you guys. So that's wonderful.
Um,
I actually took the day off of work
I not specifically for when I was my
father's birthday,
but I'm,
I got to see him spend some quality
time with his grand daughters,
which was incredible. Um, so great.
So we are here to talk about
this amazing film egg. Um,
and as I said before,
I've watched it a few times and every
time I'm catching more and more of the
complexity of the characters
and the nuances of, um,
really both what it means to be a woman
and what it means when we consider or
find ourselves faced with or decide not
to move forward with motherhood. Um,
but also what it means to all of
those around us. Um, so you know,
how our partners perceive
it. How are, um, you know,
former friends from different parts
of our lives perceive our roles. Um,
and there's really just
a ton to unpack there.
But I'd love to hear from Alicia,
David,
kind of what brought you to
this project very quickly.
Okay.
We did a reading of it almost 10 years
ago and I felt when we did this reading
that it's spoke to things, the character
said things that I've always thought,
but I had been afraid to
say and I loved it so much.
And at that time it was, they were
considering it for the stage and, um,
and I just was like, oh my God, I
want to do this. I want to do this.
And then I got really busy, like first
of all, making an actual human being,
but then also on orange is the new
black and all these other shows.
And two summers ago we were on
a ferry boat from fire island.
And I only bring that up because
it was from the town of Kismet.
So it was actually kismet.
Um,
and we bumped into the
writer and she said,
I just did a rewrite on the screenplay
version of it. Would you like to read it?
We were like,
yes.
And I felt more than ever it was these
things that no one was talking about,
about the relationship between work
and art and commerce and parenthood and
career and friendship.
And you know,
I was talking to someone recently about
how we're changing so much in reference
to gender norms and
how we talk about gender and
yet we haven't made those
changes around parenthood
and how we talk about the roles of
parenthood and we have such an antiquated
version of what a mother and a father is.
And it just hasn't caught
up to our world today.
And I wanted to bring up
some of those issues. Yeah.
It had stuck with us. I mean, yeah,
it was, we were actors by trade.
We both make a living as actors,
which is great. Um, you know, Alicia,
Alicia and another partner
produced the Wall Street, uh,
the female driven Wall Street
movie called equity. And, um, yeah,
I had just finished five years on a
Sitcom and I thought I had a break and
Alicia said, hey, you're going
to produce this with us, um,
you get to be the associate producer.
And I said, what the hell is that? Um,
it turns out that he runs around putting
out all the fires. Right. I learned that.
And then, um, uh, you know,
we really weren't necessarily sure
we want it to produce anything again,
but then we met the writer on the ferry
and there was egg again and we said,
Oh man, it's, it's so
good. And I as a man,
I love the male characters in it. I love
what the male characters have to say. I,
you know, I, I've, I was excited
about it. Um, even if, uh, you know,
even if it's quote unquote female driven
content, you know, uh, I was all in.
So when something sticks with you like
that, you know, you've got to do it.
Yeah. It's interesting to hear that
it was like a multi year process.
So just kind of sticking
until it finds its final form.
And I'll also say for me,
I like as a producer,
I need to,
I don't produce something unless I
feel like it needs a voice. You know,
there's a lot of stories that I'll
read and I'll be like, that's amazing.
But I know so I know this
will get produced. Like I
know someone will do this.
This is one of those where I was like,
I feel like too many people would be
afraid to make this movie and I wanted to
be the one who wasn't afraid to
make this movie. We're glad you did.
That actually is a great segway. Mallon,
I would love to hear, um, you know, from,
from the Lens of the Gina Davis Institute,
why was this film so important to,
to your mission?
Building off what Alicia is saying is
that there was probably a lot of people
who would pass on this because it's not
something that is obvious to be spoken
about. And why is that just even
more important to be spoken about?
It's important in terms of
onscreen behind the camera,
which I'd love for Alicia and David
to talk about it. And you know,
there's a social imperative.
So how do we take these kind of societal
norms and turned them upside down,
um, which they did, you know, beautifully.
But from a business imperative,
we just did a benchmark study,
which looked at 10 years
of films, family films, g,
PG, PG 13. And what we found
is over the past decade,
female centric films generated
55% more at the box office.
And that change happened in 2016 where
female centric films generated 70% more
at the box office. And in 2017 it
was 38% more through box office.
So it's, there's the social
imperative, which we're talking about,
but there's the business
imperative. So it's, it's really,
really important. But yet, even
still female lead characters,
there's still a two to one ratio of
male characters to female characters.
So that's not what happened
in the case of a egg.
Um,
so it's really important.
And then I'd love to throw to you to
talk about behind the camera. Yeah.
Mm. So, um, our third partner on this,
Michelle gainless who was the president
of comedy central on who had left in,
was looking into producing her own
stuff and who has now started a great
production company as well.
Um,
this was her first piece, you
know, off of comedy central.
And the thing that I loved
about Michelle from the get go,
or we loved about
Michelle from the get go,
was that she was equally committed
to hiring all women across the board.
So we hired all female heads of every
single department. So we have a female,
for example, a female writer, female
director, a female cinematographer.
And I love to talk about her because
she had never shot a feature.
Not because she wasn't insanely talented,
but because no one had given her
the opportunity. And I saw a short,
she did in Africa with children and a
leopard and they say like the two things
you should never do or work
with animals and children.
And she did this Spec Tech.
I mean the film is
spectacularly beautiful,
but this was her first feature and now
she's shot like three more in the past
two years. And female sound
design, female sound design,
female set designer,
rube or job had female camera,
camera op. Yeah,
everything. So, um, editor.
So we did all female heads of all
departments and then 70% female crew.
And that felt amazing.
And yes,
the women made as much if
not more than the men. Um,
and it felt amazing.
And one of the things that I love to
say is there was way less drama than any
other set I've ever been on.
You know, if we like have that,
the gender norms of like women are
dramatic and throw a hissy fit,
whatever did not happen,
there was no drama. Um,
we finished our days on time or early
every day and we were shooting sometimes
like eight pages a day.
Um,
and it was an incredible experience and
I think my favorite part was the emails
from women and young women who this was
their first job on a set and they wrote
to us afterwards and said like,
I've been on a couple of sets in,
it's not like egg. Even our production
designer recently wrote us and she's like,
I still haven't had another
experience like egg.
And they said,
I haven't like other
sets weren't like this,
but you gave me hope and you made me feel
like I can create that in the future.
Like when I'm the boss, I'm going to do
that and I'm going to hire more women.
And that's really why I'm sitting up here
with this woman is because way before
I made this movie,
before I made movies,
she inspired me in the Gina
Davis Institute inspired
me about if you can see it,
you can be it both onscreen and off.
And that is so deeply important.
I'll never forget when I first heard
this statistic of when you watch
anything, even a cartoon, 77%
of the characters are male,
which means any girl watching any
media feels like she's a minority.
Like that's a ridiculous concept.
Women are up 50% of the population,
but no matter what they're watching it,
when they're watching any screen,
they feel like a minority.
And just to add some context to that,
our friends had common sense media, uh,
do a lot of analyses
on a media consumption.
So your average tween in the United
States is engaging and watching media
upwards of six hours a day.
And teens are still engaging with media
and watching about nine hours a day.
It's more than sleeping school,
anything else they're doing.
So when you think about media impressions
and you think about the repetitiveness
and how it's being reinforced,
they're seeing that, uh,
stereotyped media image
over and over and over.
And it does make an impact
on how they view the world,
how they view each other.
So it's very significant.
Actually, it's a question for you on
that because we were talking earlier,
I feel like I'm starting to see more
female leads, more female driven.
We're starting to see a lot
of female superhero movies.
Is this the case of being hungry and
seeing signs for food all the time?
Or are we really seeing
a shift in the industry?
Well, in terms of this benchmark
study that we just did, you know,
unfortunately 10 years later it's
still a two to one ratio of male carer,
male leads,
you know,
to female leads and women are 52% of
movie going audience and we're 51% of the
population.
So we're not really being represented.
And when we talk about people of Color,
people of color are 38%
of the US population.
But in terms of the past decade of
film there solely 16.7% and then if you
really want to get into the
intersectionality of it,
which is an a really
important conversation, uh,
people with disabilities,
people who identify as Lgbtq are less
than 1% of any character in a film over
the past 10 years.
The top 100 films from the United States.
So we have a lot of work to do.
I'm glad you guys are doing the work. Uh,
there's another interesting facet to, um,
the film where a Alicia,
your character, Tina,
is financially leading the partnership.
It comes up in a way,
um, in a couple of different
conversations that she is, um, you know,
leading the highest household from a
contribute contribution perspective. Um,
she's spun as kind of,
you know,
not being woman enough or
not being nurturing enough.
And when you compare that with,
um,
Kiki's who is very needy
and very dependent, um,
and you know, the men, sorry,
David or like tripping over
themselves to take care of her. Um,
talk about that a little
bit about that storyline.
I think you should talk about
that. Yeah, talk about it.
I think, I believe the line in
the, in the uh, film where, um,
Tina Alicia's character says is accused
of not being nurturing and kind of
comparing the women in the room and she
says, I'm not nurturing. And just look at,
look at her. She's a
fucking train wreck. Right?
And the power of the powerless
woman, no man can resist. Hmm.
Right. And I, and additionally,
I, my character, you,
you find out in that moment is
supporting her husband is, you know,
and like how is that not nurturing?
And she says, look, I support
you wanted to do this.
I, I supported that. You want to do this.
That's where did that you want to do this?
They supported that.
It's never enough. It's never
enough. That's, and that's
an interesting thing. Um,
and it is, it is fascinating
to see, uh, the shift in,
in society. You know, um, we were talking
about this earlier or from, you know,
women who are breadwinners in their
family and make more money than their
husbands do. Um, and in this case,
I think it was one of the things I really
liked about the film and I read it, uh,
even before we made it was a
dawn. My character a is, you know,
very happy to be the
wealthiest person in the room.
He's fairly certain of that even though
none of us know anything about anyone.
Right. But he makes that assumption
and a is a perfectly fine with that.
And that gives him power over people,
especially over women.
And so it's a very interesting
thing to see the when,
when a woman is an artist,
um, self assured, um,
financially stable, I'm financial
independent and speaks her mind.
You know, it's fascinating to hear
what people have had to say about,
about that character in the film.
Yeah. And, and I like that. I and I,
dawn judges everyone in the room,
um,
and we're all judging everyone all
the time, but yeah, a little more.
So that's what makes it fun. Um, and uh,
and dawn gives voice to some of the
stereotypical misogyny that we're hearing
all the time. And, and I don't like him,
but I liked the chance to, to do
that so that people will go, oh,
or people will go, oh, he didn't just
say that. Did he just say that? Yeah.
You were a lot of audible groan when,
when I get very happy about those.
Yeah.
I have to just knowing you, I was, I mean,
it was making me laugh at every turn
because it was so antithetical to who you
are, but it was, it's almost like,
and because it takes place in,
in this loft, throughout the
film, mostly in this main area,
you kind of get this insular feeling of
almost being in somebody's head and you
have all the different judgments
or different aspects of,
of what could be firing off.
And there's a tremendous
amount of judgment and it's
coming across both genders
and it's coming across, um, different
parenting decisions. And, um,
it really to that.
And I'm curious,
did you guys have to let go of any of
your preconceived notions coming into this
film in order to portray these characters?
Like how was that for you
to see one, you know, um,
I mean, yes. I mean, yes,
right. We owe, as the actors,
we always do because we're not,
unless we're playing ourselves,
then yeah,
then we have our own preconceived notions.
But character,
the characters that you inhabit
always have preconceived notions.
Sometimes that's your way. And sometimes
the, I mean, with Donna Asleep,
he's such a judgmental asshole that I
was like, God got it. Got It. Yeah, no,
that guy. Yeah, we all know that guy.
But we may work with some of them.
May I probably not here,
not here at Google. Um,
but we've, we all know those
guys. And um, uh, I had, yeah,
I mean, and honestly I was on, again,
I was on a set that was 70% female and,
and fairly invisible unless I was in
front of the camera and they don't,
and that's not a criticism,
it's not a complaint. Um, and I,
so I had to set aside my preconceived
notion of, Oh, well, I'm,
I'm a man and I'm producing a movie
and I'm one of the big bosses. Oh no,
but he's going to come on now, let's do,
do what I say to do. What up dude, go on,
fall in line. Um, not that, not
that I was ever that guy, but, uh,
I was in a room full of smart women and
that things are getting taken care of.
And I was kind of like, it's okay
if, if I don't have to, you know,
at least we're talking about drama.
Like I don't have to yell.
I don't have to be typically male
or loud or to get things done.
They seem to be happening just fine and
it's okay if I'm not seeing it's because
there's no problems, no
fire to put out. Like,
so I had to kind of adjust what I thought
my role was going to be as producer in
that way.
Right.
What does that change the dynamic
of the set and the dynamic of the
relationships? Was that palpable too as
well from previous films you've been?
Oh yeah.
Oh for sure. Yeah. You know, um,
I love that you brought that
up because for me as an actor,
as an actor playing Tina,
like Tina has a lot more preconceived
notions and judgment and um,
her way of doing things than I do.
Like,
I think as a human being,
one of my biggest goals is to sort of
strip away as many biases as I can.
Cause that makes me a more open artist
and more able to play the widest variety.
It also makes life more interesting.
I'm just much more,
I find life much more fun if you're
really willing to listen and wonder,
you know,
our production company company is called
to wonder fold to be limited like two
people full of wonder.
And my biggest goal is I grow
and age is to keep wondering.
Like I feel like people tend to get
more and more narrow and they hang on to
their beliefs more and more as they age
where a small humans like are much more
like I wonder,
oh I don't know.
And I want to stay like that
wonder place as long as possible.
And I think Tina feels like she
knows things a lot more than I do.
But um,
in reference to the dynamic of the sat,
it was very surprising
I think to everyone.
And I didn't realize what a white
male I was married to until we were,
and this dynamic cause by the way
they're married. Yeah. It's a really like
evolved feminist white male.
But you put him in a room with a lot of
powerful women and he's still a white
man and he still can fall.
Like we all as women can fall into seeing
him as such and he still can fall into
those, um, stereotypical roles. You know,
like we all,
we all fall into our roles sometimes
on an off camera without realizing it.
Yup.
Actually, let's, um, let's roll.
Uh, we have a couple of quips.
The throw the first clip here,
I forgot. I'm, I'm not,
not actually pregnant.
We have a surrogate mother.
Oh, oh, oh, wow. Yeah, yeah.
Oh, a surrogate. Yeah. We know a
gay couple of weeks at that. Yeah.
The guy who did our a window treatments.
Did you have to go through all that awful
IVF fertility? Snow? Well that's good.
Yeah. No I can't. I mean we
can, this was more of an option.
Okay.
Uh,
sort of a utopian pregnancy,
utopian pregnancy.
It's sort of a dismantling
and restructuring of the
traditional family unit.
A redistribution of roles to a
more shared economy kind of thing.
I, you're the first people we've told,
we don't really have the wrap down yet.
So you can have the baby
yourself, right? Yes. I,
we can we choose not to.
You're paying someone to have
the baby for you. Yeah. Perfect.
I love,
I love this clip because you come up with
the notion of language and you're like,
we don't have the wrap down yet.
And I think this is something that,
you know,
we all,
we all have these judgements.
We all have these opinions that we bring
with us into certainly family dynamics
and this assumption of how things should
be or how they can roll off the tongue
or not. And when we tend to
go outside lines with what
we expect, that's where we really
start to get tongue tied. Um,
and that's why I love the vulnerability
of showcasing your character.
Just working through that with exactly
the judgments that you would expect.
What, why, what, you know,
talk to me a little bit about
the importance of that language
language. Such an interesting
thing. And as an artist,
there are some writers,
for example,
who are very specific about language.
You know,
Aaron Sorkin doesn't want you to change
a single word or a period period.
Um,
and other writers are much more open,
reset. Our writer, and this was
somewhat open, but interestingly enough,
our director didn't want us to
change a word. She's like, she felt,
and she's,
she's written and directed things.
And in this case she was just the director
and she felt that the writing was so
purse
precise that she didn't
want us to change a thing.
And she didn't want us to Improv a lot,
but she wanted it to feel like Improv.
So that moment that you just saw,
even though I'm floundering for the words,
that's actually,
that was all written as such
and language in our culture.
I think we are in this moment where we
don't have language for a lot of what's
going on in the world and we're
creating new language. You know,
um,
when I was growing up,
there was no such thing as
gender fluid and nonbinary.
And we have a 10 year
old and that is such,
it just is for her. And that's, um,
and that's such a beautiful,
miraculous thing because we
as a culture are evolving.
But this,
as I said earlier,
like the way we handled parent roles has
not of hall like were my daughter knows
how to describe her gender fluidity so
much better than we as a culture know how
to describe parenthood.
And that's to me a problem,
you know, and part of what we
were looking to delve into,
and sometimes it's my deepest tube,
why I'm an artist,
is that we can express these things
and delve into them and art as a way to
bring up conversation to then
move our society forward.
And I think you were alluding to that too,
and I'm thinking back to you guys on
the boat of this being a story that some
people would shy away from because it
does unpack those things and you can even
see the characters questioning themselves.
Am I happy?
Is this what I wanted? Was that decision,
the right decision for me? And, um,
you know,
it's,
it's just very human that grappling and
I think we don't see so much of that.
I mean,
certainly Madeline within the industry
where there's a lot of glamor and Shane
to everything,
we don't see the characters really crumble
as much on these definitive parts of
their lives. Do you have any thoughts
on that? Well, when we look at, um,
attributes and careers,
only 15% of female
characters in TV and film.
And this is from our 2018 data,
which we haven't published yet,
are shown working. Mm
hmm. Um, and then 15,
15% just showing, you know, working. Um,
and when you look at also the ageism
of it, which is another thing, um,
in the movie, um, you know,
most female characters
are shown in their teens.
Most of them are shown under 19,
only 30% are shown in their forties
and only 3% in their fifties.
And,
and so when you think about motherhood
and women having children at an older
age, that's not something that's really
being reflected, you know, in, you know,
in the media.
Um,
and then when you think about
Kinda the caretaking of it, uh,
there's very few men depicted as um,
caretaking and when they are,
you see a lot of the bumbling
yes, you know, this silly lazy,
bumbling dad and,
and we know from our friends at Promundo,
but I happened to sit on their board that,
you know,
changing the dynamics of masculinity and
really reflecting that in the media is
important because most American
fathers want to spend more time.
I think it's nearly 70% want to spend
more time with their children and that's
their data, not our data. So you know,
media is not really keeping up
with how our society is changing.
Yes. Preaching to the choir, you percent
of the dads want to be doing, by the way.
Yeah. Well what we've
done, well, it's funny,
when we did an average,
a study on gender bias and advertising,
a 48% of the female characters in ads
will most likely to be in the kitchen.
And the men were at sporting
events and driving around in cars.
So that's where they were driving
around what they're doing. Yeah.
We'll get there.
Uh, we have one, one more.
Click ahead. Equip number two.
I can see why you guys chose her. Oh,
shut up. I'll get you something to put on.
Hi, I'm Kiki. I'm Wayne and
Tina's baby surrogate mom.
I'm Karen. You're pregnant too,
right? Oh No, I'm not pregnant.
I'm kidding.
Oh good.
It's always so horrible when you ask
someone if they're pregnant and then it
just turns out that they're just, you
know, fat. Oh, well I'm pregnant and fat.
Oh God, no, no, no. I didn't mean
that. You're, uh, I know. I mean,
obviously you're pregnant.
Doesn't she look wonderful?
You have such a rosy cheeks here.
Oh,
thank you.
Awkward. So awkward,
but also so relatable.
Um, and I just, I think there's so
much packed into that one exchange,
whether it's, you know, the,
the body shaming hypersexualization
of Kiki and then there's the,
you know,
the,
the question around is she pregnant
or is she fat and why does it matter?
And why is this a public thing?
When women are carrying that,
then it's all they can talk to you about.
You know,
there's so much packed into
that one exchange. Tell us,
tell us about the scene.
It's funny. Um, I was, I did a an evening,
Liz,
I'm totally going off on a tangent because
everyone's going to watch the movie.
Watched it already, right?
That's right. Oh Man.
I don't want to like give anything away,
but I did a with time's up.
I produced an evening,
uh,
about Rebecca Traister is book or
inspired by Rebecca's chasers book,
good and mad,
which all of you should read.
It's really the history of
rage and female rage and anger.
And I did it honestly because
I'm afraid of my own anger.
I'm afraid of anger. And so
when I, in that wondering way,
when I find something that I'm afraid
of and that makes me have a pit in my
stomach, I'm like, go towards
that and go explore it.
So we did this evening and we had a lot
of different women find a passage about
rage are raging to express.
And so we had a comedian
who I love because, um,
she's a woman obviously. She, uh,
is disabled and she is Muslim.
And so she, like, she is one of
the most amazing women I know.
And she does a comedy bit about being
pregnant and about how you never should
ask anyone if they're
pregnant ever because,
or parents because people will tell
you like they will show you the baby
pictures before you can even ask.
So you never even,
and it's not even just pregnant,
it's parenthood because we assume
that all women want to be parents.
And that's a really big topic of this
movie is not all women want to be parents.
Not all men want to be parents.
And that's okay.
A woman is enough whether
she's a mother or not,
she's more than enough and that we've
created this standard and this norm that
is completely inappropriate and
lets go of any choice for women.
And that's what enraged me about it.
And it was another thing that made me
really want to make movie is I want women
to have free,
all women's have freedom of
choice in a full and complete way.
Um, so that's uh, you know, for me
with that, oh, mint is about, yeah.
Yeah. I think it's interesting how
you see the characters evolve from,
you know,
pushing each other to each other's edge
and then really coming to each other's
rescue at the same time. And I think
there's a lot, there's obviously the,
the motherhood and parenthood, um, topic,
but there's a lot to feminine
relationships that's explored as well.
And I found that really,
really powerful.
I mean,
that's my favorite thing about the
movie is these two women, you know,
Kiki aside sort of who are old friends
and really believed Dee bleed different
things,
have made different choices,
but are willing to lovingly accept and
listen to each other as choices without
making the other make the same choice.
And that to me is what true,
authentic friendship is about.
And it was another reason why this was
so deeply important for me to make as a
filmmaker in this moment because it was,
we read the script in like October.
Um,
the man people call president,
uh,
became president in January.
And I met Christina at the women's March,
um,
and it,
which was the weekend of the inauguration
and I found out that she was childless
by choice. And I thought, wow,
how interesting to make this movie in
this moment when women feel like an
endangered species.
And additionally,
when 53% of white women
voted for that human being,
um, it's a little bit of a
Baltimore thing for me. Um,
I, um, I,
I realized I wanted to also make art
about people listening to each other,
even if they didn't
believe the same thing.
And that's incredibly
important to me in this moment.
Learning how to listen without
judgment or even if you're judging,
shut the fuck up and try and really
listen and learn something and ask as many
questions and try and really
open up your heart to what's,
what can I relate to here?
What can I possibly relate to here?
And I think these two women do a
really magical job of that. Um,
and that to me is what the, the
story, the core of the story became.
And it wasn't what, I didn't know
that that's what it really was deeply,
most deeply about until the
editing room. Really. Um,
but in watching the edit it was like,
oh,
it's really about being willing to
listen and support even if you don't
necessarily believe the same thing. Yeah,
I think that definitely came through.
And in particular, uh, the
scenes with just the two of
them, then it's very strong.
I'm curious your take on that clip we
just watched in terms of what you saw
there from your [inaudible].
Well, there's a few things.
There's one clip that was in the,
a little bit of it in the trailer where
Kiki talks about kind of the five phases
of being a woman. And uh, the
second phase is boobs, teens.
And she talks about that's
when you have your most power.
But I'm in the fourth phase and I
have to be, you know, just a mother.
And then there's the other scene where
you first see Kiki and you completely see
her, you know, sexually objectified. And,
and so when I think about that and I think
about some of our new data, you know,
female characters are six
times more likely to be
hypersexualized and five times
more likely to be verbally objectified.
And I thought,
you know,
and maybe you can just talk about it,
but there's scenes in the movie that do
it with such great humor, um, and kind of,
you know, point, fun added. But truly
that's what we're seeing, you know,
in our, in all of our,
you know, family films.
So I don't know if you want to,
yeah,
it definitely was taking a ribbing at it.
Um, and that, that five phases,
I'm obsessed with that five phases.
You have to watch them. One of the
most brilliant things I've ever read,
or an Anna camp does a genius job of it.
And she,
I love that character so
much because she really,
she's kind of doing it to herself.
Like she,
her choices as a human being,
the characters traces as a human being
are so fascinating and the patterns she's
going into and without,
you know, ruining too much.
But she's in a relationship
with a married man and, um,
these, these patterns that we fall
into and her choice of what she wears,
you know, which is written into, into
the script. And we just followed that,
that lead that in a,
in a way she is choosing
this s stereotype,
um, and this, um,
paradigm of what a woman is.
And it's the diametric opposite to what
Tina is because Tina's really interested
in sort of breaking all those stereotypes.
And then Wayne's in between trying
to sort of navigate these two women,
which is, that makes it all, and
that's a very complex part of it too,
because each character. Dot.
David said earlier about Don,
like we all know that guy eats character.
We all know that character, right?
There's someone in our
lives where there was a time in our
lives where we felt like we subscribed to
very similar paradigms.
So I definitely feel like there's that,
that sense of, um, identification
that you can have through,
through each of those characters.
There's also every dinner party, we've
all ever been to gone wrong. And,
and usually,
I mean,
I think we've all been to those dinner
parties where someone says something a
little bit off and most eyes just kind
of go to the plate or someone gets an
elbow under the table or a kick
and that's, and that's it. Right?
And then you just rip it apart
on the way home. Right, right.
Like on the subway ride home. I
can't believe she said that. I want,
I know what's her problem was she
had a ride to work a day in her life.
So she's apoe and he's probably
right. And we all do that. And so,
but we do it there. Yeah, we
don't do it in the ride home.
We, we do it there. Right.
It's like we're at the table and someone
says, why would you say that to me?
The other person says,
well,
because I think your acts and the
person says you don't know me. I'm not.
Why would you say that? Like this is an
idea of how we want to live our lives on.
The person says, well, I don't
agree with that. So it's,
it's we get to live out that dinner
party fantasy that we've all had of like,
yeah, wouldn't it be great if
you could just tell him like,
nobody likes to hear you talk about x,
Y, z. We don't give a shit and you know,
you don't seem to care
about people and what,
like it's that dinner party
thing that I think, uh, you know,
that we've all wanted
to talk about and uh,
with subjects that we've all wanted to
talk about but are a little bit afraid to,
like Alicia said earlier, are very afraid
to. Um, and I think that's part of,
I hope that's part of
what happens in the film.
We've been hearing from a lot of people
that have seen it, that, you know, they,
they have questions, they want to
talk. Why did we do it this way?
Why do we do it that, you know, and that's
great. That's what we want. It's not a,
you know, you don't watch it and
be like, yeah, pretty little bow.
It's not one of those paintings.
And a lot of people have said that.
I went back and watched it a bunch of
times and every time it's different. Nice.
See different things in.
That's really exciting and rewarding.
Well, there's a moment, there's a moment,
there's a scene where as David's
describing, it's uncomfortable.
It's almost like,
I think this way sometimes when you
watch Ben Stiller's comedies like you,
you're like, no, don't, don't,
don't do that. You know,
it's uncomfortable to watch because it
puts you in that position where you feel
that vulnerability of sharing something
that you normally would just keep to
yourself or share with your
partner in the way home. Um,
but there's one scene where there's
a question that comes out and David,
your character, dawn, just goes,
well, that's a little personal and
we're talking about the most personnel
things ever. But there's that,
that dry humor to it.
It was a question about money.
Oh, right, right, right.
Does your boyfriend pay your rent?
Like why do you have to move out
of your apartment? Oh, right.
We've just talked about her uterus
or life or relationship or, yeah.
Or identity as a woman. And then I say,
someone says, well, why do you have to,
to the apartment? And I said, well that's
a little personal. We all just get along.
Again,
that unfolds.
A whole other thing is a whole other,
thinking back to your
last project with equity,
well not one on one of your past projects
with equity is just the comfort around
women and money and certainly women
and money as portrayed in media. Um,
and we, we talked a little
bit about, uh, you know,
breadwinning women and primary earning
women who are 42% of our nation.
Um,
and you know,
we're not seeing that
showcased on screen anywhere.
We're not seeing that pride and we're
not seeing that kind of expert. Yes,
I love it. Yeah. So that's
a great segue. What's,
what's up next for you guys
that you're able to share?
Is there a pardon your next
project for me. That's great.
No,
there were no men in it.
Right now I'm shooting the Deuce,
which is so much fun. Oh my God.
Where it last season was
season two. We, we shot in the,
it was the seventies
and now in season three,
it's the 80s in New York and items,
the writing is so genius and
I'm so, so, so enjoying it and,
um, better things, which I'm also on,
just started airing like two weeks ago,
I think this week.
Sharon Stone is our guest star
wars. Oh, that's terrific.
A gorgeous scene with her. She
was such a joy to work with. Um,
and um,
just to keep things even I'm going across.
Um,
and we just wrapped season seven of
orange and they never tell us when that's
going to be out. But my guess is some are,
but don't quote me. That could be a lie.
And this is the F is this the final,
final season? That's for sure.
That's for sure. And um, I've definitely
been mourning that a little bit,
but how does that feel? That's a, uh,
that's a light hurts. You know, it,
I'll miss the character because
she was so extraordinary.
And this season is quite epic in its,
um,
social commentary on what's going
on in the world right now. Um,
I'm really proud to be part of
this season for that map, for that,
for that reason. Um, and,
but more than anything, I'll miss the
people because there are some mixed,
spectacular humans both behind and in
front of the camera who made that all
happen. And I will love them
forever and I'll see them forever,
but I won't see them as much. Yeah.
Not behind bars. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hopefully not. I mean, we never
know. Who knows. She still
curious. Yeah. David,
what's up next for you?
Uh, if Alicia hires me and our next
project, then I'll tell you what that is.
We get there. I just did a show
on CBS called instinct. Okay. Fun.
And uh, yeah, trying to get a job
and, and being a hands on dad,
that's the most important job I'm very
proud of. And Alicia is a hands on mom,
but she's been a lot busier
than I have, especially since
it came out. Yeah. So, uh,
yeah, I'm doing the laundry and
the dishes and being a dad and,
and your building tree forts.
Yeah, we did. We did build a tree house to
were power tools involved. So yeah. Yeah.
You Bet. More stereotypic. Yeah.
But yeah. Big shoes to fill. Yeah.
I don't want to let, what is your
season look like coming up with?
We've, uh, we have a
really rich research year.
We're just about to published the next
iteration of what we call the Gdiq,
which was generously funded by google.org.
It stands for the Gina Davis Inclusion
quotient and it's a machine learning tool
that automates gender screen and speaking
time and actually race for screen time
using audio and facial
recognition. So, um, we have,
we're really rich partnership with Google,
so we're really grateful for that.
And this year we're releasing not
only film, which we have done,
but also TV. Uh, so that's been
really important for us to, uh,
to evolve the Gdi Queue.
So that's coming out soon for us.
And then as I mentioned,
we're partnering, uh,
with Pomono on a masculinity study.
We're also partnering,
partnering with Plan International on
a study about girl's relationship to
leadership.
So we have a lot of really interesting
research projects coming out.
And then we also are commissioned
to do a lot of research.
So we've done a lot of research
for leading brands, uh,
content creators, studios.
So behind the scenes,
a lot of people want to know how they're
doing and so will also conduct a lot of
research that way.
So important.
I'm so glad to hear it.
We are a data driven company here at
Google and I think the more you have data
telling a story, while it may not
be the story we all want to hear,
it's telling a certain story and only
then can you start to see action and start
to measure the progress. What's very,
very important work that you're doing.
I'm thrilled that we're finding ways to
partner together on that initiative. Um,
so
egg is available on Amazon
and iTunes and video on demand
coming up on Hulu as of March 31st on Hulu
31st it's a great mother's
or father's Day gift. Yeah,
exactly. We actually flipped mother's
and father's Day in my house,
so I get father's Day, my
thigh, you say. And for anyone
who's watching the global channel,
aren't you coming out internationally?
Yes, yes, yes. March
31st we open in theaters,
which is mother's Day, or
you can, Yup. Australia.
It's actually called something else there.
It's called motherhood.
I wasn't sure if you were
going to share that yet
for our UK, uh, subscribers and
counterparts, make sure that you,
he polyols other hood.
And if you follow at Alicia Reiner,
you'll get all the scoop
about it. Always. Yep.
Dates. Yeah. Yes. And for
the Gina Davis Institute,
anybody that wants to learn more,
there's some great
infographics throughout there.
I don't just think some of the
data just really makes you mindful.
Um, and that can be found
at [inaudible] dot org. Um,
so thank you all so much with such a
great conversation and really looking
forward to more success to come.
Thank you.
Bye.